another great guest off of our guy Aaron
Jones Green Bay Packers first of all
congrats on an amazing season 19
touchdowns this year you really blew up
so thank you for making time for a
little while stick to football here oh
thank you for having me Aaron what do
you think it was this year I mean
obviously a massive second year jump one
of the biggest ones we've seen what do
you you know attribute that kind of
breakout to the system and opportunity
just getting more opportunity to touch
the ball my my mountain touches probably
double maybe triple Don yeah him from
the previous first two years so I think
that was a big thing in just the way the
systems ran on but using back some
different ways getting them on
mismatches with linebackers out out wide
or running vertical routes on them and
you did great you're receiving so yeah
definitely saw I appreciate that and I
just feel like as part of the system and
taking advantage of mismatches how
different is Matt Lafleur system from
what you guys were doing under coach
McCarthy for you as a running back um
it's a little bit more outside own then
we were running and then offensive wise
so I mean sorry pass game wise it's kind
of similar terminology is a little bit
different some concepts are a little bit
different but for the most part uh
throughout football the concepts will
usually kind of be similar stay the same
so you've had two years with Aaron
Rodgers now what's that relationship
been like I know he always speaks
glowingly of you every time they ask him
but how does that relationship end I
always been great uh he's a great leader
and I'll just enjoy playing with him and
learning from learning so much from him
you know he's definitely elevated my
game and helped me continue to grow I
mean I remember evaluating you and you
were coming out YouTube you had two
great years there the one year yet was
shortened by injury if I remember right
but I don't remember you catching the
ball as much in college as you have
shown in the in the proces that's
something that either maybe I don't
remember right but is that something
just wasn't exposed as part of your game
in college um we threw it a little bit
my last year if we threw it was towards
me yeah my last year there
and then but I played I played slot
receiver in high school my sophomore
year so I kind of like that uh that
helped a little bit and uh just when I
when I met with coach Lafleur he told me
hey we like to get the backs involved
and gave me Devonta Freeman and some
other backs he's working with so some
tapes walk and watch on them and see how
you use them and so I went home after
that and start practicing myself that's
awesome we had Allen Lazard on yesterday
and yeah he was great and it just shows
that like Green Bay is developing not
only guys that are going in the first
round or these high end free agency
skilled players who were a day three
running back Allen was undrafted and
picked up from Jacksonville
what's that environment been like it's
great to see them they let you guys
compete and the best guys are getting
the reps and you know Jamal got some
reps in the backfield too but you were
the lead back this year that it's
undisputed definitely is all about just
going in there and making the most of
your opportunity and you because you're
gonna get your opportunity yes it's what
you do with it when you get that
opportunity and I'm so proud of lies
because he worked so hard and he didn't
squander his opportunity he took full
advantage and every time we kept coming
his way he would make the most of it
every play and he turned out to be a
good big key piece for us I want to ask
yourself this question you went to high
school in Texas you went to UTEP what
happened why didn't you go to Texas to
the Longhorns and we've needed a running
back what happened they recruit me
[Laughter]
no yeah it didn't I only had three
offers so UTEP New Mexico State in UTSA
well Don Charlie Zhong is no longer at
Texas well he wasn't he wasn't there I
think Mack Brown was still there well he
would have recruited you to play safety
anyway just misses across the board yeah
actually Charlie might have been there
my last year in college I think because
we play yes slept on coming out of high
school slept on a little bit coming out
of college and I mean I know you played
on the same team as will Hernandez and
you got a good offensive line now just
what's it been like we're gonna have
that group some veteran guys some young
guys Elton Jenkins had such a good year
this year
he's gonna he's gonna be a great for us
and yeah it's gonna be a great one for a
long time in this league and I told me
continues to work and put his head down
and ground he's gonna be special because
I mean he's already shown shown it this
year what he can do and he's only gonna
continue to grow what do you think the
offense is missing you know we talk a
lot about like getting younger tied in
adding another wide receiver to go at
the Fontaine and Allen what do you think
is missing I would say just consistency
just like how this last game San Fran if
we play like we played in the second
half we played we like that in the first
half like it's a little bit different
game it's uh we're in the game so yeah
it's it's you know easy to sit here and
say you had what looked like you had
more fun this year you won 13 games of
course you had more fun this year but
what is a different energy that Coach
Lafleur brings every time they cut to
the Green Bay locker room you guys just
just felt different this year I was a
Brotherhood in there if it feels a lot
like college oh you guys you have group
of guys hanging out I mean I spend more
time at other guys house then I did my
house this year and usually I just go
home and be by myself you could just
tell the Brotherhood guys enjoy being
around each other and we all want each
other to succeed so just just the love
that's also how much of that starts with
Aaron at quarterback and kind of
trickles down you guys or is it more of
a skill player thing I just think his
all-around but it definitely does start
with our leaders um I definitely would
say it starts with Aaron Siderius
Mercedes Lewis
Preston some of those guys um and and it
goes on down the line so but those
definitely guys who started I got to ask
you
where'd the sombrero start from I think
you said originally it was your
girlfriend's I guess my girlfriend's
idea she she bet me I wouldn't know my
boy I've been wearing one ever since
actually a Packer fan after where the
first one it was just a black like
costume one yeah he gave me up and I had
to you in a row so I've been wearing
that one on every game day so how crazy
sauce go from El Paso to Green Bay
it's definitely is this super cold
going from the desert to like the North
Pole's with Mexican food or is there any
dirt like a possible my girlfriend
Mexican food but no nothing like cooking
no no peso yeah we know you're running
around here on radio row and it's a lot
of the same questions but what are you
doing off the field what are you doing
to have fun it's it's time to take a
little break little rest and recovery on
just listen to artists perform nice I
got to see Meek Mill perform yesterday
wanted to I want I want to see a little
while you perform Delano yeah right
that's this tonight huh yeah I think so
many NFL players have found out where
we're staying and Allen Robinson is
hitting us up hey hey hey can you give
me the room key gets you to that we
would be the the people opening the
doors to furlough Wayne well have fun
with it enjoy it and we look forward to
seeing where you go next year you know
what happens as your games to continue
to develop so maybe that BP season we're
rooting for man yes sir
it was pretty close to thank you thank
you close but I can definitely get there
and you'll be back yes sir
thanks fantasy MVP next year for sure
are yes sir thanks man